I'm grateful that they didn't try and
redo that one scene from the original
Top Gun when all planes come back in and
everyone's on the flight dead cheers and
they're having a party this plane could
explode there's the party okay let's try
it
again
[Music]
well I'm a lawyer he's a former Judge
Advocate it's time to see what laws were
broken in Top Gun
Maverick
[Music]
okay last time we did this I pointed out
that Maverick was riding a motorcycle in
California without a helmet uh Tom Cruz
is driving a motorcycle very fast in
California with no helmet and everyone
in the comments said oh Top Gun was
created before they had a law in
California that said you had to wear a
helmet while riding a motorcycle well
guess what it's still Top Gun it's the
sequel and it's in present day and he's
not wearing a helmet might be Petty but
it's a $250 fine uh and or a year of
probation oh yeah uh it's whatever fine
I said it was in the first one it's uh
probably a misdemeanor at most but Devon
is this in Nevada now I don't know
man sorry that literally just occur to
me I keep cutting you off the is that
knees it it doesn't matter cuz Nevada
has a helmet law too so wherever he is
in the west I guess he should be wearing
a helmet and you should
too and just to be clear it applies on
military installations too he wouldn't
even get through this gate without the
gate guard saying yeah man put your
helmet on you know better there's
actually more restrictions on a military
base than there are just riding around I
think that you're absolutely
right
hey what is
it what we've been ordered to Stand Down
The Scrap in the
program I don't know why they're the
ones that are telling him he's like the
Project Lead and and I guess main test
pilot you'd think he'd be the first one
to know that sometimes the bad news
travels down then up now remember the
contract threshold is ma 10 not 10.1 not
10.2 ma 10 that's the program of from a
defense Contracting perspective hitting
that kind of performance on like a
decades long program is probably not
going to be be the thing that makes this
LI or die and I don't think it helps
their case when they say we did this
unsanctioned flight after you literally
ordered us not to do
it uh M Admiral Kane is asking ordering
that we bring her
down
asking this is where we've had trouble
with Comm sir it's the Earth's curvature
it's called Earth bulge did anyone offer
you a coffee it's article 92 the uniform
code of military Justice you have to
obey orders by Superior commissioned
officers and he just got one and he
disobeyed it so it's I think very funny
uh that he's doing the whole like I
can't hear you thing on the cell phone
there would probably be a recording of
like every Transmission in the craft
itself I will also just say as an
officer by saying I'm not going to
follow this order from a superior
commissioned officer you can sometimes
get your senior enlisted in trouble
which is exactly what Maverick did he's
not the only one on the hook here that
Senior Chief or whoever he is uh who's
working with him that guy's in trouble
too
oh don't do it don't do it just I don't
care about the like legality of it or
the realism of it but it's just like
it's such great storytelling of having
him just push a little bit too far U
even though he's screwing over
absolutely everyone that's on the
project absolutely but you know that's
his character he's got to go he always
has to go to the N degree he always has
to go one more to sort of a zone of
danger uh perhaps uh a a danger zone if
you will yes yeah yeah like he's on a
highway to it one would
say oh
Maverick I know you were never a
pilot I'm not either uh I'm not a
physicist but it feels like if you're in
the upper atmosphere and you're going
mock 10 and your playe disintegrates
feels like that would be absolutely
instantaneous death for the pilot I I
mean I remember when the space shuttle
fell apart and those astronauts didn't
make it they were going probably
something like that and there was not
much left behind I mean unless he has a
capsule like the president of the United
States had in whatever movie that was
Air Force yeah Air Force One Air Force
One he's got a capsule like the guy like
the president in Air Force
onein this is Ace One emergency pod
destroyed I don't know if that's uh
equipped on this particular experimental
craft especially because he's just
walking around um in his suit
distinguished
distinguished yet you can't get a
promotion you won't retire and despite
your best efforts you refuse to die you
should be at least a two-star Admiral by
now if not a
senator yet here you
are
Captain why is that he's captain captain
in the Navy it's a Naval rank it's not a
it's not a ground rank so he is the
equivalent of a colonel are there active
test pilots who are captains SL Colonels
that seems like an awfully high rank to
be flying some experimental craft it
does seem like an awful high rank and
especially because the the higher the
rank that you are the less time that
you're actually able to spend getting
your flight hours in to maintain your
proficiency for reasons known only to
the almighty and your guardian angel
you've been called back to Top
Gun if uh one General says you're
grounded and I have ordered you to do
something and you have disobeyed those
orders can someone with a higher rank
overrule those decisions and orders it's
kind of like a metroad doll you can have
a colonel giving an order to a
lieutenant and say I ordered you to do X
but if you get a general or an admiral
who's above that Colonel can't they then
say I order you to count to reverse that
order absolutely it's just orders all
the way down or up when it comes to the
military you have people who are
superior ranked but you also have kind
of silos and if someone from one Silo
they can give you some orders to a
limited extent but if you're not in the
same Silo it is limited what you can
actually order someone to do ultimately
you have to get one person above that
covers the whole Silo all silos and
sometimes it's that kind of game of
politics where you can get certain
things to happen even if you don't have
direct authority over someone that
you're trying to get to do something got
it is an unsanctioned uranium enrichment
Plant built in violation of a
multilateral NATO treaty the uranium
produced there represents a direct
threat to our allies in the region once
again they're being completely generic
about all of the the bad guys it's
already such a jingoistic nationalist
movie that there's no reason to vilify
whether it's Russia or Iran or North
Korea they're just the bad guys and
frankly I miss movies where it's just
like this is a generic bad guy and we're
going to fight them because they're
really terrible without having to get
into the actual real real life
geopolitics of it all yeah they did this
in the first Top Gun and it was great
what's your read
Captain well sir uh normally this would
be a cakewalk for the F35 stealth but
the GPS jamming negates that I mean my
read is this is the star Trench
Run with better graphics yeah I mean
100% two Precision bombs minimum makes
it for aircraft flying of pairs that is
one hell of a steep climb out of there
exposing you to all the surfaced air
missiles or you survive that but like
f18s are not made to have a second pilot
as the bomb operator aren't almost all
of them single seaters although there's
still plenty of uh two seaters so in the
back you've got the wizo the Weapons
Systems officer who can do a lot of that
work of lazing the target basically
taking the actual Pilot's mind off of
the delivery of the Munitions and that
way you have two minds instead of one
but isn't that why you would use an
actual bomber to the come on it's
Hollywood we're going to make this
exciting we're going to do it we don't
want you to fly it we want you to teach
it teach
sir we recall 12 Top Gun graduates from
their squadrons we want you to narrow
that pool down to six I love that this
movie is just Top Gun college Years like
here are the people that graduated from
topun we're going to bring him back and
uh teach them some more now I I should
mention you were actually stationed at
myar close to San Diego where all of
this is taking place I was but that was
in like a legal capacity so you don't
really absorb a whole lot of knowledge
of actual flying and weapon systems and
stuff like that when you're a lawyer sad
to say many lawyers would disagree and
think that they're experts on everything
it's not true but later I did become a
jtec and I was calling in close air
support and dynamic targeting missions
in Iraq and that's how I got most of my
knowledge so you were serving as a Judge
Advocate in and around myar well you
went to additional training became a
jtac and served in Iraq and learned more
about I guess you'd call it close air
support I mean it I had probably the
most convoluted and bizarre career
history in the Marine Corps but yeah I
was a Judge Advocate first and I
retrained to be an artillery officer and
became a jtech
Bradley Lieutenant
Bradshaw yes sir I mean I have to
imagine this is not a situation that
comes up very much but these two have
prior history is there any kind of Prior
history even as convoluted is this that
would create a conflict or a problem
between a superior officer and someone
that they're commanding it's not like
with lawyers where they may have what we
you know an ethical Conflict for
representing one person if you don't
think that you can command someone
because of some interpersonal history of
some kind it's really your obligation
and duty to inform your Superior officer
and maybe get reassigned your or have
that person shuffled around a father
should not be commanding his son or
daughter once you get further enough a
field though a cousin or you know a
grand nephew I think it becomes less
important is there anything that rooster
could do here and say we have all this
prior history I don't think I should be
commanded by Maverick he could go above
Maverick and request Mast and say I
don't think I'm going to get proper
treatment I don't think that uh he's
going to evaluate me fairly but I don't
think that's going to go very well 5,000
ft is not just a rule it is a law as
immutable as Gravity the hard deck will
be much lower for the mission sir and it
will not change without my approval okay
so yet again we have a hard deck that
was violated what's old is new again I
guess a hard deck for this Hop was
10,000 ft
you knew it you broke it what do you
think the violation of that would be
here I mean it has not changed since he
did it in the first movie and if he
can't follow basic orders then he's
going to be reprimanded exactly like
what's happening here he's not going to
go to jail for it he's just going to get
you know kicked in the crotch one Twi
Top Gun Rules of Engagement exist for
your safety and for that of your team
they are not flexible nor am I and to
refresh everyone's recollection what
does it mean that they have violated the
hard deck in this uh this training
scenario well the hard deck is the
notional ground right they have to treat
the hard deck as if it is the ground and
that's because they don't want to have
very much variation where they're saying
the ground is the ground oops I just
went down a little bit too low yeah now
I'm dead yeah you need to have literally
did you need to have some buff room in
there and while in this movie and
perhaps in reality under the
circumstances of this plot he may not
get in a lot of trouble it's actually a
really big deal I mean it is actually a
pretty big de deal to violate the hard
deck in any sort of training Mission I
think most Pilots would agree with that
the in in the training Mission they're
both considered dead they both hit the
ground once they hit 5,000 feet right
right exactly right and so when Maverick
is talking about well the hard deck's
going to be lower that doesn't really
make any sense because the hard deck is
the ground so if they're flying at 5200
feet at in actual reality that is
notionally 200 ft above the hard deck
the Navy needs
Maverick the kid needs
Maverick that's why I fought for
you that's why you're still here I mean
I don't know about you but when I saw
this in the theaters I was on the verge
of tears like I think this is one of the
greatest callbacks and one of the best
uses of like time passing in a sequel
that I've ever seen plus you have the
reality of valkill actually having
throat cancer um just like everything
that they've done here is is such good
screenwriting I I just I love the the
relationship here yeah I mean I think
you could have gotten writers and
producers who were angry about this
situation right angry that they couldn't
bring Val Kilmer in in a very specific
and certain way but like not only did
they roll with it but they worked with
Val Kilmer to make it work and frankly
made probably more POs to the actual
story yeah and it shows that that the
character evolved since the last movie
but not in every way just in some ways g
i I love this so much Maverick to range
control entering Point Alpha confirm
green range uh Maverick range control uh
green range is confirmed I don't see an
event scheduled for you sir well I'm
going anyway nice okay that seems like
uh exhibit number one in the court
Marshal he's no longer the instructor I
assume at that point he no longer has
authority to you know fly a plane at all
Pilots like anyone else they have to
follow range control rules you can't
just go randomly into a range whether
it's flying or doing something else in
the military because you have no idea
what other people are doing someone else
could be flying you don't know that I
mean how do you how does Maverick here
know no for a fact that someone else
isn't using that particular airspace for
some other reason remember back to the
original Top Gun when all he did was fly
low over the deck over the Airfield when
he had been told there's not going to be
any flybys it's a serious fight
it's not a joke like he could have hit
someone trying to take off similar thing
here it's actually incredibly dangerous
yeah this is actually uh that seems
worse when he did the flyby in the
original he was cleared to be flying
here he's not cleared to be flying or
using the range at all with the Airfield
example it was more dangerous cuz there
were more possible other aircraft doing
things I think at least he gave them a
heads up that he was going to do it and
gave them some time to respond here he's
just saying I'm doing it we're doing it
let's go you have put me in a difficult
position captain on the one hand you
have demonstrated that this Mission can
be flown perhaps the only way it could
be
survived on the other hand you did it by
stealing a multi-million dollar military
aircraft and flying it in such a manner
that it may never be airworthy
again Iceman is no longer here to
protect you I have everything I need to
have you court marshaled and
dishonorably discharged now obviously
Maverick would have needed a good lawyer
for his court Marshal but if you wanted
a great lawyer my firm the eagle team
can help if you've suffered a data
breach especially if you got a data
breach letter were involved in a car
crash or dealt with sexual harassment we
can represent you or help find you the
right attorney who can it's so important
to talk to aoer right away so you get
the best representation and find out all
of your options so just click on the
link in the description for a free
consultation with my team because you
don't just need a legal team you need
the eagle team the link is below he's
not going to get a dishonorable
discharge really even if he's Court
marshaled he's not getting a DD no huh
when you have an ' 06 who does something
like that where it has a greater purpose
which is to show that a mission could be
flown right even if he's Court Marshal
even if he's found guilty he is not
going to get a dishonorable discharge
it's just not going to happen maybe he
gets retired at a lower rank he is not
getting a dishonorable discharge not for
this I guess I I assumed that if you
were found guilty at a court Marshal
that the punishment is commensurate with
a dishonorable dis discharge it's not
automatic you could be convicted of what
are considered felonies General Court
Marshal many of them and not get
discharged at all so what are some of
the ranges of sentences that you would
get that doesn't rise to the level of
dishonorable discharge you could get
years in the brg potentially without
getting an actual dishonorable discharge
no kidding the military sentences have
multiple different factors whether it's
jail time or Brig time uh a discharge of
some kind a punitive discharge
forfeiture of pay and allowances all
sorts of different things and each one
is kind of considered an isolation so
ultimately when the sentence is
announced you could be dishonorably
discharged to get no jail time you could
also get jail time but not dishonorably
discharged or discharged at all but the
biggest reason that he's not getting a
dishonorable discharge is because
officers don't get dishonorable
discharges they get something that's
called a dismissal so if you're
dismissed from the service that's kind
of like a dishonorable discharge in a
lot of ways but technically it's not a
dishonorable discharge that is reserved
for enlisted members of the military
only no kidding Maverick getting off
without a dishonorable discharge the
fact that he's still lying as an ' 06
after all the stunts he pulled on the
original Top Gun that's Hollywood
magic thank
you if I don't see you again
Hondo thank you I assume this was
Maverick's highest enlisted at the like
test program is there any reason why he
would be reassigned to some random
aircraft carrier for this Mission and
working the flight
deck in in the military all things are
possible that doesn't mean all things
are equally probable I have a really
hard time imagining how this is
conceivable but who knows excuse me
counselor my answer yes or no is it
possible yes yes it's possible damn
you Tomahawk Airborne no turning back
now this would be a declaration of war
not a congressional declaration of war
obviously but it would con it would
constitute an act of War for the
purposes of inter AAL law just pull out
all the stops guys yeah you know you're
going to war with this country if that
country has the the wherewithal to do it
yeah I think you know the only kind of
limitation on the reaction of this
hostile country is they may not want the
world to know that they had some sort of
uranium enrichment facility to begin
with guess so that may on a political
level stop them from responding in the
way that they there you go it makes
everything makes perfect sense dagger
you are not to engage repeat not engage
two return to carrier
acknowledge acknowledge okay so rooster
has an order not to engage seems like
that's an order that he needs to abide
by is that disobeying an order if he
decides to go back and engage there are
exceptions carved into that particular
rule under the uniform code of military
justice so if you are given an order not
to cross a street but you see a child on
the other side of the street who is in
dire need of help and will die if you
don't do it you run across that street
you save that child you have disobeyed
the order but you haven't broken the law
and similarly I think rooster has a
pretty good case here for I was doing my
best to save someone else's life I know
you gave me that order but I was acting
to save someone's life who is an
imminent threat of serious physical
injury or death and that is a competent
defense under the law okay sure but here
you have a downed pilot and a pilot
remaining in an F18 it kind of feels
like there's not a whole lot that you
can do here you know so Maverick is
going to get shot by a a hind helicopter
what what was he supposed to do other
than than that I guess yeah I mean I I
he could rooster could have followed the
order he could have returned back to the
carrier in Maverick's dead and probably
the worst ending possible to top one
Maverick but that was a possibility The
Producers had that choice they didn't
make that choice and I get
it
[Music]
the other thing to keep in mind is in
the example I used about the crossing
the street the order that was given
doesn't contemplate the child across the
street so that's why the violation of
that order makes a little bit of sense
and why he shouldn't be held accountable
this particular order though it does
contemplate where Maverick is The
Situation he's in and so I think that
the idea of this defense of uh defense
of others I actually don't know that it
would actually work because the order
acknowledges that Maverick's going to
die yeah I saved your life I saved your
life that's the whole point what the
hell were you even thinking you told me
not to think so so rooster and Maverick
are Behind Enemy Lines they've been shot
down uh any reason they can't steal an
F14 from not Iran um and uh escape with
it you're not serious no but I think
they're probably fine doing this there
is a concept in the law of arm conflict
called perty and in fact it's against
the Geneva conventions to engage in
something called perty I don't think
that they're actually engaging in perty
not to the extent of any sort of like
War crime or something like that I think
what they're doing is perfectly
reasonable but you know who knows an
overzealous prosecutor not myself could
do try and do something just wave it
smile just wave even
Smiles so here they have used an enemy
F-14 to shoot down a fifth generation
fighter isn't that like pretending to be
wounded and then shooting an enemy
soldier as they come near isn't that a
violation of the Geneva Convention under
the facts of this film no it would have
been different if these hostile aircraft
had thought that they were in fact part
of their Air Force and then gone ahead
of them and something like that and then
Maverick had shot them down I think that
could potentially have been a problem
because that means they really are
relying on a misrepresentation about who
they are here though the enemies clearly
did not believe that they were actually
part of their Air Force they pretty
clearly understood and they were the
ones who actually began the engagement
for all intensive purposes plus it was
just a really awesome scene so I mean
All Is Forgiven yeah I agreed there's no
greater defense than Victory or just
being awesome
yeah
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen I'm
grateful that they didn't try and redo
that one scene from the original Top Gun
when all planes come back in and
everyone's on the flight de cheering
that drove me insane they're in the
middle of combat operations and they're
having a party no this is I like this
this is better yeah this this is an
emergency you know everyone's not
popping champagne on the flight deck
exactly like this plane could explode
yeah and we could be getting shot at by
God knows what at any moment
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah never mind no no there there's the
party okay let's try it
again
well so much as I like this movie it's a
far superior movie than the original but
they just had to do it they had to do it
to get under my skin where once again
just like the original they have the
this party on the flight deck when all
these people get back you are in the
middle of combat operations you are off
the shore of some hostile Force you have
no idea whether they're sending a bunch
of air frames out your way to attack
you my god get back to your station's
people get going leave yeah and and this
is an enemy that's equipped with the
latest generation of Fighters with
stealth like go only knows what's coming
their
way all right and now it is time to
tally up all the crimes in Top Gun
Maverick so while plenty of laws were
broken in this film I think it's fair to
say that no one's actually going to get
Court Marshal it's just not going to
happen it everyone has matured and I
think Society has matured since the
original Top Gun such that Maverick
really didn't commit nearly as many
crimes as he did the first time around I
I think it's safe to say that he's going
to get a medal and uh then be pushed out
the door and retired as soon as humanly
possible with a $250 fine for not
wearing a helmet while riding a
motorcycle now if you like this video
don't worry this isn't the end we have a
longer director's cut version available
on today's sponsor nebula which is much
much longer where Spencer and I do and
even deeper dive into the legal
intricacies of top gun Maverick on
nebula you can watch all my videos add
free and early because my videos always
go up on nebula first plus there's tons
of exclusive content for example when
you sign up for nebula direct you get
access to nebula classes which includes
my entire course how to sue like a
lawyer that used to be hundreds of
dollars a year now it's free and
included with your direct nebula
subscription you also get access to my
nebula only videos like my full
documentary bad law words good as well
as the Deep dive that we took on Trump's
mental state and the various crimes he's
accused of and the crimes that Steve
Bannon was pardoned for and I know tens
of thousands of VI signed up for nebula
using the Curiosity stream bundle but
unfortunately that is over curiosity
stream informed us and they've included
in their latest SEC filing that they
don't intend to pay us for bundle
Revenue through 2024 this means that I
won't get any money for bundle
subscriptions and the bundle is breaking
and you won't be able to access nebula
through curiosity stream anymore maybe
I'll make a video about what happened in
the background on that soon but if you'd
like to support me and this channel the
only way to ensure that that money that
you spend on nebula goes to me is to
sign up directly and my friends and I
make exclusive nebula content all the
time that includes exclusive videos
original series movies plays classes and
more all with your favorites like Johnny
Harris Neo jetlag real engineering real
life lore and of course legal eagle we
create the content that other people
react to because what's truly special
about nebula is that it's a
creator-owned platform built by me and
other YouTubers and podcasters and
because it's a subscription service we
get to work on larger higher budget
Productions than we ever could on
YouTube so if you sign up using the link
on screen right now you'll get an annual
subscription for just $30 which is 40%
off the regular price you'll get my
videos early get access to exclusives
and support the ambitious projects that
my friends and I are working on on our
own streaming site so sign up now and
get 40% off by click on the link below
and get nebula for only $30 a year after
that click on this box over here for
more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court